[Music]
uh
yeah we're live from thank you
well good morning everyone and welcome
to devon building control partnership
item one on the agenda apologies for
absence
i believe we're all present so there's
no apologies to be given
thank you item two declarations of
interest
do any members have a declaration of
interest can i just say
terry i can't see you on screen so i
have to flip across
right
nobody has any interest chris
no no interest gentlemen
right so it was that that was terry i'll
i'll flip across to catch you
council appears right okay
moving on then to item three which is
the minutes of the
previous meeting which was on the 17th
of july
2020 um are there any points that anyone
wishes to raise about
the minutes of the 17th of july
is it your wish that this signed there's
a correct record please
somebody like to move let's
councillor bastown seconded please
counselor pierce yeah okay thank you
all in agreement please sure hands thank
you that's
everyone thank you
right so those are approved
that was item three item for
the operational report part one that's
the part that's
in this part of the agenda
um okay can i ask
um the carpenter please to take us
through any points that come up under
part one
yes um morning everybody uh first of all
the some of the items will be expanding
upon a little bit more
in part two to just bear that in mind uh
the main items i want to
[Music]
highlight in this report uh
let's scroll down um
we've had two two members of staff left
the partnership
um in the last six months
which we had one that retired back in
the summer he was part-time anyway
um and it was
intended not to replace him during the
current financial year
the other one left at the end of
september
and i've said discussions are in
progress regarding
future resources i now intend
to replace that full-time post
so at the moment a request has gone to
slt for formal approval to go out and
advertise for it
the and this is any questions i'll
mention a couple of other things
importantly i think
covid19
in the earlier lockdown for a couple of
months
we've basically didn't go out on site at
all that was our
initial reaction saying um
preventing any non-essential travel um
that seemed to work very well we didn't
really have any issues we
we use virtual means to assess things on
site
since june we've returned to
um not no lockdown
and visiting sites but not all sites
we've carried on with virtual means
and several staff had to continue with
isolation anyway what's um happened now
of course with snow
uh the second lockdown uh we are doing
some site visits
um we we've cut out non-essential visits
but we did realize that perhaps there
was an element of risk with some
inspections particularly
anything below ground foundations where
we couldn't necessarily
would have seen everything as well as we
could have on virtual means
so we risk assess the visits when they
come in and
determine whether they do need a site
visit or not
other than that they are now on back on
virtual means
and we have some discussions and perhaps
in part two we may discuss it further
um on exactly where that takes us in the
future because we're still
learning um as to to how far to go with
this method
once once cobit is finished um
those the only things i was going to
highlight in the report it's a fairly
short report there's
not a lot else to to say really during
the the the last six month period
um i think it all speaks for itself but
if there's any questions i'm happy to
answer them
thank you are there any questions from
anyone
yeah terry thank you chairman
councillor pierce thank god um
yes i i'm a little bit concerned about
william elliot's
uh observations the teamwork climate
change officer
whereby he states that uh
there might be implications on the
energy and carbon performance of
buildings because of restrictions on
physical site visits
i mean all developers know what the
regulations
are now so one would
require them to work to those i just
wondered whether
uh andy or mr carpenter had any
uh views on those uh observations
thank you all right wendy i i have to
admit
on reading that again i don't think i've
really picked up on that when he wrote
it
um i'm wondering whether he means
there's an effect on the buildings
because you're quite rightly saying that
they need to comply with the
burden regulation requirements whether
we're visiting them or not
it shouldn't make any difference and i'm
thinking he's thinking
the the implications are more likely to
reduce
the carbon footprint on our traveling to
visit those
the actual buildings themselves should
be constructed the same whether we
we physically visit those or not uh and
i think it's something i need to take up
with william
i i haven't i must admit i haven't
really read that and thought about it
but
um it does seem to read that the
buildings themselves will be affected
so i'll make a note of that and speak to
him okay thank you okay thank you
yeah right anyone else
no okay in which case um the
recommendation is to note the report so
would somebody like to move that
uh we note the report
yeah that's gary sorry counselor taylor
seconded by councillor kimber
okay can i have a show of hands are
those in favor please
right that's everyone thank you okay so
that's carried
right so that was item four
moving on then to item five which is the
recommendation
under section 100 a brackets for the
local government act
1972 the present public be excluded from
the meeting during consideration
of items six and seven on the ground
that they involve the likely disclosure
of exempt information as defined in the
relevant parts of
sorry paragraphs of part one of schedule
12a of the act
so i'd move that recommendation as that
seconded please
that's councillor birch seconded that um
and those in favor please
okay that's everyone so that's been
carried
in which case uh we now will go into
part two so i'll have to wait for chris
to tell us that the youtube streaming
has been
turned off before we continue please